it's been years since the opposition
Enclave in Northwest Syria replaced the
local currency with the Turkish lira
authorities here wanted to protect the
population from the currency's collapse
but not long after the economic crisis
across the border in Turkey spilled into
this region the Lira too lost its value
and now there is a new problem
look at this customers don't accept to
take these banknotes neither do banks or
exchange offices all these banknotes
should be thrown away we need a solution
some sellers have started to refuse
damaged bills others accept them only if
their value is reduced
business owners say they face a
difficult Choice
many of our customers are poor and all
they have are damaged bills it's a
problem for me if I accept them because
I can't use them and it's also a problem
for the customer who needs to buy things
across Northwest Syria there are a few
ATM machines and few people have bank
cards that could reduce cash in
circulation but in the province of idlib
there is another issue the area is
governed by the so-called salvation
government which is Affiliated
which is considered a terrorist
organization by the International
Community
turkish-affiliated financial
institutions don't operate there
something should be done to resolve this
problem we already had issues with the
US dollar old banknotes lose up to 40 or
even 50 percent of the value because
there's no institution to replace them
some are now questioning the benefits of
using the Turkish liver at all
two non-governmental